dominique verdeilhan vous êtes en direct
avec nous depuis le palais de justice
donc ce n'est pas une surprise cette
révision
elle n'est pas encore décidée on va
attendre une demi-heure mais c'est vrai
que si on ne fait pas beaucoup de
pronostics en matière de justice ça
serait une énorme surprise si les
magistrats ne décidez pas en début
d'après-midi de la révision du procès de
patrick dils puisque doute il y a ce
serait également un événement judiciaire
parce que depuis 1989 date de la
nouvelle procédure des révisions pénal
il n'y a eu qu'un seul précédent avec
reed allouche alors j'allais dire la
seule incertitude c'est l'éventuelle
remise en liberté dès ce soir de patrick
dils
ça serait logique eu égard aux textes de
la présomption d'innocence en vigueur
depuis janvier 2001
mais l'avocat général au cours de ses
réquisitions s'était opposé à cette
remise en liberté
d'abord au nom de l'ordre public et eu
égard aux familles des victimes
ensuite pour protéger patrick 10 jusqu'à
son nouveau procès alors un nouveau
procès si l'ia qui aurait lieu devant la
cour d'assises dès mineurs vous exercez
surprenant puisque patrick 10 est âgé
aujourd'hui de 30 ans sauf que ces
larges au moment des faits qui entrent
en ligne de compte
et à l'époque patrice avait 16 ans